[Música]
esta trigésimo quinta edición debía
celebrarse a finales de abril de 2020
aplastada por el confinamiento a
finalmente tuvo lugar justo antes de la
segunda y contra todo pronóstico a
mediados de octubre en estricto
cumplimiento de las normas sanitarias el
festival de web más importante certamen
internacional de moda fotografía y
accesorios de moda ha captado como cada
año la expresión y el espíritu de su
tiempo el reciclaje
lo que es especial en estos jóvenes es
que casi nacen con eso y para ellos es
mucho más natural que para nosotros en
cualquier caso y en muchos niveles de su
vida diaria
pero los que fueron elegidos representan
de una manera nueva este app cycling
este sistema de reciclaje inteligente
que es hermoso
el problema con el reciclaje durante un
tiempo fue que era bastante feo que no
queríamos estos objetos en absoluto
incluso si eran reciclados y protectores
la gran diferencia de los accesorios
premiados es que quieres usarlos
juana y tu tu etcheberry son hermano y
hermana nacidos en el suroeste de
francia en el país va ganaron el gran
premio hermes de accesorio con este
brazalete gran premio de accesorios de
moda con estas gorras y sombreros
totalmente reciclados todo comenzó
cuando vi la pila de contenedores de
plástico en el basurero de hecho
pensamos por qué no usar estas
curvaturas de los envases de plástico
para hacer viseras de tapas en realidad
nuestro proyecto no podría haberse
realizado en casi ningún otro lugar
nuestro producto final está hecho de
botas de un industrial local de
paracaídas de cámaras de aire de
tractores
el circuito que tiene un sombrero
así que maceta de plástico para de aire
de tractor gota de como antigua
boquillas de recipiente
también debemos recordar que de dónde
venimos de hecho hacen alpargatas y
tratamos de reutilizar la punta del
pistón
por ejemplo cocida a mano
poca cosa el plástico con goma con velas
de parapente complicado
las botas de goma eso está en el tallo
eso es lo que tomamos y luego lo
cortamos con un chorro de agua es un
industrial local el que nos permite
hacer eso así que hace los sombreros
comparte escaladas eso es un trabajo de
sombras y luces de claroscuro en parte
se expone a la mirada y en parte se
oculta el concepto expuesto oculto es
inherente al amor a que el dúo amplifica
ahora con una ráfaga de preguntas
perdidas que revelamos tanto hoy en día
a través de las redes sociales no
deberíamos tener que escondernos de
hecho físicamente que queremos mostrar
de nuestra intimidad en la sociedad y
que nos permite la sociedad mostrar
bueno mostrar era realmente sobre esta
protección que queríamos trabajar con
nuestra investigación
para crear su colección en el salón
internacional del textil y la moda
premiere visión patrocinador histórico
del festival reúne a los aspirantes al
título de mejor diseñador del año ya los
productores de tejidos de ln
cuando ves todo el trabajo tecnológico
que se hace hoy en día para hacer
productos a medidas para evitar generar
residuos da mucho optimismo sobre la
moda y toda su maravillosa inutilidad
que nos encanta gente con aldo el belga
tom van der burgh ganó el gran premio
del festival tuvo varias vidas
trabajador social artista visual creador
de vídeo comenzó a diseñar ropa un nuevo
tipo de ropa tarde la vida ahora tienen
42 años
es muy importante hoy en día despertar
esta idea de lo precioso piezas hechos
humanos
esto responde a la pregunta de redefinir
nuestra relación con el planeta pero
también con los demás tiene que ver con
los materiales utilizados
cuero de pescado plásticos abrazaderas
industriales con van der box mezclan
nuevos textiles y residuos
una
siempre sentí cariño por las cosas que
otras personas tiran o que otras
personas piensan que no valen mucho
realmente quería buscar el lugar
materiales normativos un poco extraño
y yo como buen seguidor de arte
performativo tomba under box fue a
buscar entre sus recuerdos para
construir su colección
crecí en un pueblo bastante pequeño de
flandes
ser creativo era artista entonces
descubrí que era gay y después me enteré
que nací con una enfermedad muscular así
que siempre tuve ese punto de vista de
ser diferente de los demás
en su trigésimo quinta edición el
festival de jeff de destino y las
nociones mismas de moda ilustra
resumidas en esta máxima puede llevarlo
si te atreves porque es hora de
liberarse de todas las restricciones
[Aplausos]